And so, I'm very delighted to present the
final talk in this session.
So I will speak about empowering cancer research with
AI scientists, and will highlight several projects throughout
this presentation that are all fully open science
academic research, and linked from our lab website with a number of tutorials and
examples of usage.So our overall vision is
to move science from human-only science to human-AI
co-science. And as many in this session and
in this conference, we're thinking about agents or AI
scientists or AI co-scientists as conversational AI
systems that can work collaboratively alongside cancer
researchers to help generate refined hypothesis, analyze
biological data, and design experiments.
Now, in order to take a regular chatbot, a large
language model, a reasoning model, and lift it up to
become an AI co-scientist or AI scientist, what do we need?
So then fundamentally, we need to think about two questions.
The first one is that of an AI co-scientist need to be
able to use the kind of tools cancer researchers already use in their
everyday work, meaning they should be able to query research data,
clinical data, scientific literature, execute,
perform, and compose new computational biology workflows,
query machine learning models, and so on.
Second, they need to work collaboratively with human researchers,
meaning that we need to think about appropriate human AI collaboration
strategies
that allow human researchers to steer, guide,
control, provide oversight, as well as feedback to
the analysis these agents perform.
And ultimately, that feedback might also come from broader
environment, such as experimental and platforms or clinical
research tools.
As we know that a rising tide lift all
boats, the question that we're asking in my group is
what can we do to help all biomedical AI agents
and lift them up to go from agents to actual co-scientists?
So we have developed a Tool Universe.
Tool Universe is an integrated harness or scientific
environment of 2,000 scientific tools
that is available at aiscientists.tools, and it'll allow
anyone to build a co-scientist from their favorite model
agent reasoning model.
How does this work? There are really just two big steps that you need to
implement. One is a user select a large language
model of their choice. We're doing that in a fully transparent manner,
meaning that a large language model can be a close to us form
frontier LLM. It can be a reasoning model, or it can be an
open weight large language model that in your settings believe
might work the best for your use cases.
Second, Tool Universe specifies an AI tool interaction
protocols, novel ways for AIs to communicate with each
other
in order to connect that LLM to a 2,000
scientific tools that allow an LLM to now query experimental
data, computational models, and scientific tools.
And that makes AI co-scientists ready for your use.
We have seen from November 25 until February
26, Tool Universe being used for over 200,000 analysis
by users across 113 countries, 60 installations just
in the last month alone. It has been selected as an official connector by
Anthropic, so those who might be using Claude models to do various
scientific work, you're likely already using Tool Universe without being aware of
it. And there are many, many other open science biomedical agents that are
powered by Tool Universe.
This allows now you to also build your own agent by
specifying a set or a subset of those 2,000 tools that are
relevant for your research, spanning from molecular, to cellular, to
clinical
domains, and build AI agents and scientists for your
applications.
What I want to do in the rest of my presentation is highlight a few
agents that are powered by Tool Universe and show how
we can use them to empower biomedical discovery.
So here is an example of such an agent.
We call it Medea, and Medea is an AI agent that takes as input
an omics-based objective for a task that it has to
complete that's specified in natural language prompt.
It might be a task that human researcher would describe to an agent that
it has to complete.
Researcher might also provide broad experimental instruction
that an agent has to do. And then what this
co-scientist powered by Tool Universe will do, it will create a
research plan with a step-by-step analysis of what
datasets it will query and how it will analyze them.
It will defer to human researcher to get a thumbs up approval or
iterate with human researcher on the research plan.
When the research plan is confirmed, it will
be passed to an analysis module that will write the code,
debug, and execute it to complete that research analysis.
What will happen in parallel is that agent will
also consolidate scientific literature in order to collect
evidence from the scientific literature relevant for the objective to be
completed. And so the outputs of these two parallel
tracks, analysis of primary research data together with
analysis of published scientific literature, will all then
be passed into a broader overall roundtable discussion module
with the goal to, A, consolidate the evidence from different
resources, B,
model and understand the fact that sometimes the evidence might be conflicting,
inconsistent, or not aligned with each other, and then produce the
final output to human experts in a contextually relevant manner,
even potentially being able to say, "I don't know," which those who develop AI
models might appreciate. It's actually very hard to technically achieve
these models to say, "I don't know," because they would always like to make a
prediction.And so
this MedEA agent can take now a
variety of open-ended omics-based objectives, and it will
perform analysis of data in order to generate
useful insights. What can those insights
be? So here is an example of those where we challenged
MedEA to analyze
two more microenvironment profiles from patients that were
considered to put on an immunotherapy.
And specifically, the user task for a given patient looked
like the one shown on the right part of the slide, where there was a tumor
microenvironment profile provided to the MedEA agent
in the form of an actual file that contains the RNA
expression level readouts, together with some of the clinical
information about that patient, such as information about
cancer type,
background demographic information, tumor mutational burden, and so on.
And so the big question was, is it possible to analyze this
TME profile of a patient jointly with understanding
of predictions made by established biomarkers based on
this clinical and demographic data to estimate whether a patient would
likely respond to this specific therapy?
And so what we can see here on the right, this MedEA box that I'm showing on the
right part of the slide is the kind of output of MedEA agent.
It will actually query a number of different machine learning models,
computational databases such as human base, literature
search agents. Here, it decided to query Semantic
Scholar, OpenAlex agent. It would consolidate
inquiry model that can analyze tumor microenvironment
profile to ultimately make a prediction for this patient.
And what you can see in the bottom of the right slide is performance
of this agent shown as two bars in
blue,
relative to other models, specifically chatbots that would
be just prompted to solve a specific problem.
And we can see clear lift in performance in these models, in these agents
being able to identify and accurately predict those
who might respond from considering only pretreatment
data. And the accuracy here is particularly impressive given the
relative
high imbalance data set that these clinical
cohorts come from. Importantly, the reason why you see two bars here is
because this agent can be powered by any large language model or reasoning model
of your choice. That's the flexibility of easily swapping the
backbone and going from there.
So not only these agents can make predictions, but
leveraging variety of tools that exist within their toolbox, they
can query the data to
analyze, in this case, patients' tumor microenvironment more
deeply and specifically generate interpretable maps such as those
two maps that are shown on this slide that shows
how the agent has created an internal
representation that go from the raw expression levels of
individual genes in the TME
and map that through internal gene scores, gene
pathways, and then broader immunological signatures on which it
then relied on to making a specific prediction about that patient being
responder or non-responder. And all that was possible because
this AI scientist is not only querying what exists in parametric
memory of an LLM, but instead uses a very broad toolbox.
Here are just some of the tools that this agent is using, and one of the tools that
I want to briefly highlight here is this COMPASS model, which is a machine
learning model, foundation model specifically for analyzing
TMEs that is in Tool Universe. And so I
want to just walk you through what it entails developing the model and then vetting
such a model that becomes a tool in Tool Universe that others can then
use.
So COMPASS specifically is a transformer-based
model. Specifically, it's a concept bottleneck transformer, which is
a type of transformer architecture with certain specific properties that make
it appealing for
performing well in settings where the amount of label data is very
minimal. And so we do pre-train COMPASS on a
large through self-supervised learning on a pan-cancer dataset for
patients that were
treated with variety of cancer therapies, followed by
fine-tuning that pre-trained model on a small
patient datasets for specific cancer types,
indications, and immunotherapies, with the goal of then this model being
able to predict treatment outcomes to help with a
variety of analysis that agents using this model can do.
So it's been pre-trained on 10,000 tumors across 33 cancer types.
The concept bottleneck transformers can ground this foundation
model in prior knowledge from immunology through 120
immunological concepts. And then to vet COMPASS model
before it becomes a tool in Tool Universe, we
validate it across 16 clinical cohorts with treatment-naive time
transcriptomes and downstream treatment response
results. And so what we can see here on this analysis, this
show so-called leave one cohort out type of experiment where
COMPASS sees the data from 15 cohorts, and then it has to
make predictions about patients in the left out 16 cohort that
has never been encountered before.
And we can repeat that for each and every cohort to really see how well this
model can generalize from one cohort to the other, which is
important to ensure in order for this model to be
added as a tool to agents, which we can assume will be applied
to variety of cohort types. And relative to 22 other
standard immuno biomarkers of treatment response as well as
ML models, it performs very favorably.It can also
generalize across cancer indications or specific
cancer subtypes when it is presented
with patients with those cancer diagnoses that were never encountered
in the training and development time.
And it can compare favorably against TMB PD-L1
immune phenotypes being used
as a way to cluster patients into subtypes in informing survival
certification. So this is just one tool and how it's
developed, vetted before it's added to Tool Universe.
And there are 12,000 of those tools in Tool Universe that would
broadly cover probably almost all aspects of biology that
you can think of. How do we evaluate these type of
models in a prospective manner? So we have made this
agent available to our collaborators across 29
organizations throughout United States that are part
of Chan Zuckerberg Initiative's Rare ASONE network.
And we ask disease experts from those
institutions to ask a number of questions
and pose objectives to these agents.
And then
these type of questions or objectives were passed to the agent to solve,
and the agent produced the final response.
Might be response number A, and another competing model
produced also response number B. And these disease experts have seen
the two responses from the two competing models and were asked to
score and evaluate them. Which one is better?
How do the two compare? And they didn't really know which one
is the agent that we just discussed and which one is just a competing model.
So this was a blinded experiment. And so what we have found is
that when we look at AI scientists in green dots relative to
a reference model in gray dots across eight
evaluations measures including cognitive
traceability, clinical relevance, accuracy of content,
completeness and alignment, and task success, performance of
this green model, in this case, our AI scientist was scored
much favorably over a reference model, which would be a state-of-the-art
LLM without having the ability to use tools.
Just final note about how we can go from retrospective to then
increasingly more important real-world evaluations with human-in-the-loop and
then to prospective evaluations.
We connected this agent with a system of
5.4 million electronic health records and ask it to
generate potential novel hypothesis about whether
specific patient populations might be a higher or lower risk for
adverse events or outcomes in the cases when they are on very complex
patient treatment regimens. And so here the AI scientists
generate those predictions, and we apply the novelty filter to
filter out those predictions that correspond to what is already known about
the efficacy and safety of these drugs based on drug labels or
clinical guidelines.
So what we can do then next is when we can generate bank of those
hypothesis, of which we then have another auxiliary arm to the
agent that sample hypothesis from that bank
and then emulate clinical trials using real world evidence data
from 5.4 million EHR records. So here the agent
predicted that individuals with diabetes, with ischemic heart disease as the
comorbidity who might be taking DPP-4 inhibitors might be high in risk
of hepatocell carcinoma. And then we perform a variety of real
world analysis with causal inference adjustments to see whether
this is a phenotype that is seen often in real
world populations and could not be explained otherwise.
Here's another example around decreased risk for squamous cell carcinoma that could
not be explained by any of the adjusted confounders
for patient populations that would be defined by only
subsets of individuals who might have a primary disease or comorbidity,
medication, et cetera. And we can test and validate that
against a set of negative controls and positive controls.
So with that, I'll stop here and make a final note on thinking
of the future as we see it, where agentic collaboration does
not only happen for individual tasks or objective to be
completed, but really where agents can collaborate over a very extended
period of time.
We know that science is iterative, where ideas can improve through exchange,
through criticism and refinement.
That has led to tremendous progress in human
science, so we believe that similar can be achieved in human AI coscience as
well. And so if you're interested in learning more about this, I very much
encourage you to check out our Open Scientist
AI initiative. That is an open science community where we are
running AI agents continually to solve big problems
through iterative multi-round experimental lab-in-the-loop campaigns.
And I'd be happy to chat more and take more questions about that.
So with that, I'll end my presentation here.
There is a final part of this R session, which is that
of broader general discussions
with questions and answers.
So
I'll invite my two co-speakers for this session to come back, and
we'll take questions from the audience.
Okay, great. Let's start there.
Hi. Yeah, thank you for the interesting
talks. I'm Alicia with Merck. And I was just
wondering, so I think the part of establishing trust in what an
AI agent tells you is proper and thorough benchmarking,
right? And
for benchmarking, you need also kind of well-defined
ground truths, which I guess for fields like digital pathology,
arguably, you do have more information of, let's say, better
annotated-... digital images and things like that.
But for problems like recommending what kind of treatments for certain
patients, we may not have thorough
information in it, right? So I was kind of wondering, is there a structured and
systematic way for benchmarking the reasoning capability of AI agents at
this point? And related to that,
are there caveats to how we should interpret and interact with these
AI agents in different applications?
Happy to start. So,
it's such an important question. There are a number of computational
academic benchmarks that have been developed over the last
several years. One common strategy for benchmarking these type of agents
is with so-called arena style evaluations,
where there is a notion of an arena in
which there are a handful of agents competing with each
other,
and then producing, solving task, generating outputs, and then
human experts evaluate them, and the identity of
those agents who generated the outputs is blinded.
And so that allows for effectively human in the loop type of
evaluations by comparing the outputs from different agents to each
other.
This arena style evaluation was, for example, the evaluation that
I just showed in this past presentation.
I think there is beyond that also an opportunity to not only evaluate agents in
retrospective manner, but also prospectively with
lab-in-the-loop type of approach or active learning strategies, where
the agent generate hypothesis and then they are evaluated on
data sets that were left out from model training or they're
generated by new data being generated experimentally in a
wet lab or in clinical research. So the emulation clinical trials that
I showed is an example of such, where evaluation data in
particularly HR system and was
institutionally guarded, so we can guarantee that none of that information
was leaked into the training or development of the
underlying large language models that are powering these agents.
But certainly evaluation using publicly available data set is particularly
challenging, because largely the backbone large language models powering
agents might have encountered and seen everything that's accessible over the
internet.
Yeah, I can only second that. We are also actively working on
benchmarking these models and developing new benchmark
data sets, particularly designed for pathology.
We have
currently in the process of putting something together, which is called Pathology's
Last Exam, that is really looking at really, really
difficult
diagnoses. And we are actively pursuing this as well
because it's so important. Yes.
Yeah, I'll just add from the clinical side, we often have a challenge where
there is so much ambiguity in a label that
you can't rely, certainly not on a single expert human label.
For example, with the adverse events, you can very reasonably argue that a patient
may have a Grade 2 versus Grade 3 event.
Two clinicians will label it differently, reasonably, but if
you
systematically use only one preference, you'll get very different outcomes in your
trial. So it's really important to evaluate how the
rate of agreement between your expert oncologists.
And then with the agents, as they become more performant,
we are going to increasingly run into an issue that they may be doing tasks
that we don't have human experts who can oversee it,
and that's where I think it's going to become even more
important to evaluate the
stepwise breakdown of the agentic workflows.
It might be easier to say, "Okay, did it query the right database for
the question?" than it is for an
human to say, "Is the final outcome correct?"
We'll take one there.
Mark Mulkin, neuro-oncologist at the Cleveland Clinic.
So for a year,
we've been using an artificial intelligence scribe, Ambience
is the product,
to create clinic notes. The first
time we meet a patient, or if it's an established
patient, the first time we're meeting them where we haven't used this before,
I take a minute to explain that we're going to record this on my
phone.
It means that I can pay attention to you, and I don't have to be writing notes that
I can't read later.
That I will answer all your questions, so you don't have to write down the
answers, because they will be in your after-visit summary,
and that when I move the conversation from
my phone to the computer,
your private health information is no longer on my
phone. So if I lose my phone, it's not out there.
Do you know
how many people in the last year refused to let me do that?
One
out of hundreds of patients.
99+% uptake. So I'm puzzled by your
last slide that showed that for that kind of
category, only
55% of patients in the survey
answered, "Yes, you can do that." And I wonder whether it's the
design of the survey or whether the minute that I
spend educating the patient about this new
technology is really the key to the uptake.
Yeah, I think it's a great question.
I don't
want to speak too much to how that survey was administered by Cancer Nation.
I think there's something, though, very different than when you're sitting in front
of your physician who you trust, who is, as you just
beautifully described
explaining why the benefits of using this technology,
how the risks, for example, to patient privacy are being
mitigated is enormously beneficial in engendering
trust. So I think it is one thing to say, "We're using AI to
respond to your questions." Patients might push back on that.
But just having a conversation and having a moment of shared decision-making
might get us 90% of the way to
a more trustworthy relationship with AI, both for healthcare
providers and the patients.
Thank you. We'll take a question there.
Hi.
Logan Nye. I am an MD turned computer scientist, so now I build
AI for oncology full-time. I have
two questions, both inspired by the last presentation, but I'd be
interested to hear what each of you thinks about this.
The first is about the notion of causality.
You mentioned in the last
presentation that you used causal inference to
quantify certain clinical effects.
What role do you think causal inference will start to take in
medical applications or clinical applications?
And then the second question has to do with world models, especially as it
pertains to AI for science.
What role do you think world models are going to play in terms of building up this
representation of cancer and cancer biology therapeutic
response? How do you think that that's going to come into play when we start
deploying these in the clinic?
Yeah, both are great questions. Regarding the first one, which is that of causal
inference, I think fundamentally in science as it is
about pushing the boundaries of knowledge beyond what we currently know,
it requires and we aspire to be
able to distill some of predictions and insights into
more
useful mechanism understanding.
And so I showed two examples that go in that direction.
One was that of Compass creating these type of personalized
maps that are generated through counterfactual inference,
where an agent is effectively asking what if questions
and specifically saying, "Well, what if the value of a specific
gene would be flipped? How would that change the downstream
prediction and the output that the agent produces?" So you can think of that as
some form of in silico perturbation on the TME profiling of those
genes to arrive at... And it does so systematically,
in order to then identify a set of core
genes, maps to gene sets, to ontological gene signatures, and finally the
output it generated that the agent relied on the most when
making such a prediction.
And so that can be helpful because it becomes a human interpretable,
distilled version of the internal process of reasoning
that the agent
went through, through this multi-step analysis as generating the
output. The second example that I showed was an
example where an agent uses a variety of established,
vetted tools from causal inference analysis.
This is incredibly rich field that has advanced
so much over many decades of research in understanding about
adjusting for confounders in appropriate manner and do that analysis
very thoughtfully. And so here the agent that is crawling electronic
health record system, then generating hypothesis, is putting them in the bank,
retrieving them from the bank, and running causal inference analysis on them,
that creates an opportunity for one how can marry
very rigorous, well-established principles of causal inference
that are
presented to an agent as tools that agent can
follow as protocols and tools that it can follow and query, and
then evaluate this novel hypothesis through, in this case, real world evidence
type of analysis. So I see an important opportunity here
to, A, both equip agents with ability to
use advanced strategies in interpretability and
explainability to create these data-derived mechanisms that can
be further investigated, and B,
use established or techniques from causal
inference and make them available to agents as tools.
The second question relate to world models.
I think world models are just a phenomenal new class of AIs
that are concerned that fundamentally have two, for
those in the audience who might not be familiar with them, have two modules, which
is a unified representation learning module that is typically a
multi-model that can take different types of patient or
molecular data and generate embeddings from them.
And then second, which is this action module that makes a world
model really an effective simulator of specific
type of
experiments that can be done in silico.
And then see whether
if these world models would be successful if one could perform certain in
silico simulations of the experiments that would be sequential in nature
before they are done in real world.
So I think it's very exciting to see the promise of world models.
There is tremendous success that world models have achieved in robotics and
autonomous driving. The big challenge for their success in
biology is really domains for which the data is sufficiently
abundant to be able to train world models and endow
them with some understanding of the spatial physical world in which these
world models operate. I think spatial biology, for example, might be
with multi-model patient data might be one domain worthwhile exploring
first.
Any comments?
That was an excellent answer. I have nothing more to add.
I would second that as well, yes.
All right. Thank you.
We'll take one from that end.
Hello. Deepen Sangro Decker from KSQ Therapeutics.
First of all, I'd like to thank all the presenters for the fantastic presentations
and contributions to this field.
This question is primarily for Dr.
Sitnik, but please feel free to chime in
for the entire panel.
So,Oftentimes when we see examples
of prompts to these agentic tools, the questions are
very simple. Or what's the context of the gene in a
particular disease? However, as we know, there is no question
that exists in a vacuum unless you are completely new to the field or testing a
model. All the questions exist in a broad context of previous work being
done in that research group, in that
department, and so on. So how do we provide that
context to the agents itself so that the agents understand
the full context of the question behind that question, right?
So as an example,
previous experiments that have been done in the lab for 10 years
leads to that question that is being fed to the agent, and the agentic tools and
the external databases have no awareness of that data or understanding.
So of course, you can say that you can build tools and feed your data into
RAG databases and have the tools be aware of
that. But is there a balance between
providing that context as a very extended prompt to the frontier LLMs and
have it reason through the questions?
Or should the frontier model delegate it to specialized
agents and databases trained on your internal data for
a better answer? So, have you done any sensitivity analysis to see which
gives a more informed answer, whether it's better prompts, prompt
engineering, or tools are trained on your internal data sets?
Thank you.
Yeah. That's such a great question.
So we have done
quite a bit of benchmarking and sensitivity analysis across
all frontier models and then also some of the leading
open science models. And generally, what we found is that prompt
engineering can only get you that far, and beyond that, the
biggest gap is that of context generalization.
Simply knowing what is the strategy in
the lab, what are experiments are
possible to do, what is experimental feasibility of the lab
that would, for example, test hypothesis generated by AI agents.
So the way we think about this now is effectively think about an AI agent or
co-scientist as a digital member of your group,
of your lab. And similarly, as you might have a new postdoc, PhD student,
research scientist joining the lab,
it might take a bit of time in the beginning for that new
person to familiarize with the resources, the data
sets, the style of asking questions, the approach
that a research group takes to answer those questions,
strategies to validate and evaluate
hypothesis. That part of onboarding
process is also relevant for agents as
they are becoming potentially or being evaluated as
being some form of digital research assistants or digital
members of
a lab and a group. And so the way this can be
achieved nowadays, in spring of 2026,
predominant use is to think about developing tools that can be
trained on public or combinations of private data.
There is an emerging area concerned with the notion of memory or memory
modules, where it is possible to create transferable memory
modules that
can store more information than the size of the
context in LLMs through prompt engineering.
And then those memory modules can contain some of those tacit knowledge that
exists in the group and can be transferred around
with agents so that the agent can generate hypothesis that can
be feasibly tested, for example, in the lab, or can
query the data that is relevant for the specific type of
research questions that the labs are asking.
I think those are great questions and just quite a bit of research
to be done
to pushing the current state-of-the-art on biomedical AI agents in this direction.
Want to add anything?
I think that's an excellent answer.
We observe similar things, that it's not that
important how you prompt the model, but the quality of the data that
you provide the agent with is more important. Similar thing.
Okay. We'll take one there.
Hello. I am from a cancer clinic in a Norwegian hospital,
and I was very interested in this example of using agents
as monitoring adverse events. But I'm just wondering, for
the agents to access the multimodal data that
they are dependent on to predict, they have to be in the environment,
and this data is highly regulated.
So how do we solve this conflicting interest?
Perhaps I can start concretely responding to this question
about in the context of the study I presented, and it's such a great
question. And so
when I think the kind of environments that do not
tie an agent to a specific fixed set of tools or fixed
large language model powering the agent is quite an important
consideration. So in this specific example that I illustrated,
we
have run evaluations in two different ways.
So one is in subset of sites in which evaluations were
done. We were fortunate to have private instances of frontier large
language models that could power an agent.
And there were certain sites where that was just not allowed or
not possible because of the institutional restrictions.
And so
to address that,
our approach was to just change the backbone large language
model for the agent and experiments done on that
site so that the backbone was not a frontier LLM.
It was an open weight large language model
for those hospital sites that was then locally
installed at that site, and none of the data from those
hospital sites left the hospital itself.And so the
advantage of creating these type of shared environments is
that where there is flexibility to connect the
scientific environment with a variety of different large
language models can accommodate for some of the constraints
regarding sensitivity of the data, that
is a big question at specific institutions.
And so for our adverse event monitoring system, we are running
it within our clinical environment, which is, of course, as
you mentioned, highly regulated.
Our institution has a HIPAA-compliant
OpenAI inference point, so that's why we're able to use GPT.
We also have created versions with open source models for institutions that don't
have access. But what you said is such a great point, and I think it
speaks to the challenge that what we found is developing the
models and the technical methods
was
only one-fifth of the challenge.
Most of the time that we spent getting that model up and running in our
clinical system was tackling those other four
points,
integrating the agentic system within our data
warehouse, networking that ensures
data security and privacy protection,
in some cases establishing the appropriate governance boards,
creating associated monitoring and oversight
mechanisms. That really took a lot of time, and I think speaks to
the need right now for almost
the science of implementing these
systems. It's not worked out. There's no one size
fits all. And it takes a lot of
interdisciplinary effort between computer scientists, the clinicians,
IT,
legal, governance committees,
the whole host of people who have a
stake and have expertise in the different challenges
to safely implement these really, really new systems that have both clinical
implementation, safety, and legal implications, and regulatory implications.
Yeah, 20, 80% sounds about right. So I think this is a universal
constant, and maybe it's comforting
that this is a common problem that we're also facing as well.
We have time for another question there.
Okay. Thank you, for your talks from these
three presenters. And I'm a PhD student from Peking
University.
I study
computational spatial biology. And,
since the professor just mentioned the spatial biology,
and I wonder how can you
integrate the spatial
multiomics and even pathology into
the media? And, do you think it
can contribute greatly to the spatially informed
biomarker discovery and the response
prediction?
Yes, this was also a question, how much of the tools
in the tool universe are pathology related?
I actually checked that before this seminar. Around 200.
Wow.
And so there are already some of the tools that relate to
spatial biologies, computational biology in particular.
And if you go there, you can see different categories of tools.
So you can quickly navigate which are that exist there.
That said, this is also a very fast-moving and fast-advancing field with new
data being generated across different platforms.
And then that leads to several foundation models, for
example, including multi-model foundation models being trained and developed, which
can then be made available to agents as
tools. And I think Sebastian kind of highlighted a
few of those that are in the literature.
Okay. And my second question is about how can media
handle the contradictory
signals? For example,
if the transcriptomics predict good response, while
pathology or the spatial biology indicates
immunosuppressive microenvironment.
So how can media
metrics these two contradictory
signals?
Yeah, so in the example of that agent, the way it can handle contradictory
signals that might come from different data modalities or from
research data and published literature, is that through each
step of a multi-step analysis, the model is tracking uncertainty
associated with the data and uncertainty associated
with the model assumptions that are being made about the
data. And so when that uncertainty would reach or exceed
specific threshold specified as false discovery rates
by the user,
then the model would stop with its
reasoning process, and it would defer to human researcher,
to then provide additional input or guidance or
bring in additional information that would resolve the conflict.
If that is not feasible, the model abstains from making a
prediction and therefore would not
definitively predict a label or say yes and no, but it would
bring out a kind of what are lines of evidence for and against a
specific conclusion that
would then need to be deferred to human to
investigate further or resolve it based on their level
of their expertise and goals.
Thank you so much.
Okay, thank you. Since we are kind of one minute after
the end session, I see there might be a few more questions.
I would encourage those questions and discussions to
continue during the break. I would love to
thank our great presenters, Sebastian
Forster and Daniela Bitterman, for sharing their research with
us, everyone here for attending our session.
I hope that you have
learned new things and were inspired by just the
wonderful research that was presented.
And with that, we'll conclude this session.
Thank you everyone for attending, and enjoy the rest of your day.
Thank you.